gyneco doc gynéco vas-y tu peux aller tu
peux aller la rejoindre
ils vont te dire des trucs dans
l'oreille d'accord c'est la science
selon doc gynéco comme on nomme oui je
vais poser des questions bien à igor et
grichka si je retrouve ma fiche aussi la
productrice mumble me donner dans
l'oreille je vous posais des questions
l'accord sur la science à lui donner la
réponse dans l'oreille et doc gynéco
devra la donner aux téléspectateurs
c'est des questions qu'on s'est tous
posé d'accord et vous bien entendu vous
avez la réponse
voici la première question pourquoi le
ciel est bleu richard
parme
pourquoi le ciel est bleu doc y est les
bleus pas dire que
on vient de tenir la lumière
du soleil reflètent sur la mer ça fait
voir le ciel bleu
[Applaudissements]
attention pourquoi on pleure quand on
épluche un oignon ce que vous le savez
vous à eelv à venir vas-y est bas alors
là on est tranquille pourquoi on pleure
quand on épluche un oignon alors d'elle
parce qu'après vous faire la cuisine
tous si c'est ça alors c'est quoi c'est
pas ça que tu as compris de ce que tu as
dit gandhi qui y règne un acide dans
l'oignon qui agressif pour la rétine
avatar passer ça c'est de la cible de
soufre qui au contact avec le christ à
la baisse à créer une réaction de
valérie a expérimenté de salaire c'est
que dans l'oignon
il ya du soufre en fait ce que l'on nous
répond filiales et dans un oignon
exactement évidemment quand on le coupe
ça libère le souffle est sacré l'asim
sulfamides exactement année dernière la
dernière question attention
pourquoi l'eau de mer et elle s'allie
vas-y doc je sais je sais c'est déjà
tout ça je le sais pas non non non non
je ne sais pas si ça n'arrive à me dire
fait de demander pourquoi le whisky est
à cordes de grêlons et pourquoi y at il
quelque chose que tu veux rien alors eh
bien il y aurait une machine inventée
qu'il permet de dessaliniser la mer non
mais là on vous demande pourquoi le lot
2 les verts et salées du chlore il ya du
chlore mais je ne sais pas quand le
chlore est arrivé un décor qui est
arrivé à des nombreuses années lumières
du chlore s'est installé dans l'eau
douce de la mer oui oui oui il ya eu
l'idée c'est quoi le voilà à mon
explication est assez extraordinaire
parce que c'est le volcanisme c'est donc
au moment il ya deux milliards et demi
d'années né volcan était encore très
déchaîner sur terre séchée
ils ont évidemment il fait valoir tous
leurs jaillissements dans l'eau et ils
ont libéré du chlore dans l'eau et ça
s'est combinée au sodium 5 laissa donc
créé ducasse et elle l a fait et bravo
elle a plus plus ciel moi c'est moi
c'est effectivement ne l as et neutre
bien sûr exactement
allez une dernière question dernière
question pourquoi y at il du vent ont
élus arrêtent alors qu'à stadiers on
pourrait lui demander aussi c'est tout
et 108 avec les clash s'est faite un
dîner avec vous faites un kiff sans
regret il ya du vent m que dire ce qui
va ou ce prono on écoute pourrait-il du
vent bien lorsque le côté 90 articles à
bas va croiser le côté l'autre côté qui
est pas terminée adapté que sont pas
terminés la technique tactique et le dr
[Rires]
wayne rooney c'est oui lorsque les vents
venant de ces deux endroits pas fini se
croiser
ça fait du vent soir c'est ça ces noces
en personne que c'est une question de
pression bien sûr mais oui pourquoi
parce que si on sait qu' il ya des
hautes pressions d'un côté les basses
pressions de lire et lorsque les hautes
pressions sont en vente à basse pression
c'est comme une rivière qui va se
glisser çà et là il a le nez au vent
c'est essentiellement dû à la différence
de température entre ce qui est chose
qui est froid l'internât sûrement si ça
fait des millions d'années qui a dit ça